binary search an algorithm for finding
an element in a sorted array by
continuously chopping the search area in
half the first known implementation took
place around 200 bc and ancient babylon
on clay tablets used for record keeping
but your brain has likely implemented
binary search in everyday life without
you even knowing it imagine looking for
a word like magic in the dictionary you
wouldn't flip every page until you get
to m instead you open it in the middle
if you overshoot to the cues then you go
to the middle of that chunk this time
you undershoot to the js so you do the
same thing again but in the other
direction until finally you find the
page you're looking for easy enough now
it's time for your technical interview
you might be given a question like given
a sorted array write a function that
returns the index for the given element
the easy way to solve that problem is
with a simple for loop just loop over
every element in the array until you
find the one you're looking for that
works but you failed the interview
because you need to go faster a regular
loop results in linear time complexity
but you can do better than that here's
how we might map out a binary search on
a whiteboard first we need to figure out
the middle index instead of starting at
index 0 we start in the middle if it's
equal to the target then we return that
index but if that element is greater
than the target we know the target must
be somewhere on the left so we find the
middle of that slice of the array but if
it's less than the target then we know
the target is somewhere on the right so
we repeat the process for that slice of
the array the result is a much faster
algorithm with logarithmic time
complexity because it's able to divide
and conquer now to implement the code we
could use an iterative approach with a
while loop or a recursive function
either way is acceptable but let's
define a recursive function in
javascript the function takes the target
value as an argument as well as a
starting and ending index first we have
a base condition to stop looping when it
reaches the end of the array at which
point we know the target is not in the
array from there we compute the middle
index then we check to see if that
middle index is equal to the target at
which point we can return because we
found the element we're looking for
otherwise we need to continue searching
and that's where recursion comes into
play if the middle value is greater than
the target then we'll call the same
function but this time we'll put the
ending index at the middle the other
possibility is that the middle value is
less than the target in which case we
can also recurse but this time we'll put
the starting index in the middle and now
we have an algorithm that can find an
element in a sorted array much faster
than a regular loop if you want to see
more videos about algorithms on this
channel hit the like button and let me
know in the comments thanks for watching
and i will see you in the next one